ما هي دقه هذا الخبر وماذا عن التفاصيل
من حاكم هذا الاقليم في ضواحي موسكو
ويبدو ان الاجواء الروسيه اليوم تشهد
تحركات غير يعني واضحه المعالم او كما
اعلنت السلطات الرسميه مجهوله ليس فقط في
نواحي موسكو سقطت مسيره وانما ايضا في
مدينه في جنوب روسيا ثلاث سيارات اوكرانيه
ايضا سقطت ايضا شهدت منشات تخزين لشركه
تروس رادار محاوله هجوم من سيارات يعني
عليها متفجرات
وهاجمت هذه منشات النفط ولكن بحسب السلطات
الرسميه انفجرت هذه المسيرات على بعد 100
متر فقط من مستودعات الوقود ايضا مطار تم
اغلاقه اليوم او اغلاق الاجواء في مدينه
سانتربول بعدها شوهد جسم غريب طائر على
بعد نحو 150 كيلو متر من مدينه سالبه
الاسبوع
حركه المقاتلات للتعامل مع هذا الجسم
الغريب
ومن ثم بعد ساعات تم فتح الاجواء مره اخرى
وحسب المتحدث الرسمي
ان هذا الوضع الراهن ما حدث في حدث في
سانتربول يخضع لتحقيقات وبحث من قبل
الاجهزه المختصه ولم يعلق المتحدث باسم
الكرملين على هذه الاحداث في انتظار نتائج
التحقيقات الاجهزه الامنيه
مراسلنا من موسكو مازن عباس شكرا لك على
كل هذه التفاصيل